[Music]
two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about where the [ __ ] we
want cuz nobody else who is normally
here is here and my bosses are gone
they're all gone so now the kids will
play in the crew take o it is a hurry
take over yeah so for this
off-the-record we're just gonna sort of
go around in a circle and like sort of
introduce ourselves because I think that
some of you guys out there might know a
little bit about us but I don't think
that you guys have ever really spent
that much time with us in general so
just start off let's go with Antoine
Antoine our editor what Tommy points my
heading just like so when I was born
yeah okay well yeah but Antoine so no
Antoine's one of our editors JK party
here honestly like honestly one of the
show runners for JK parties was I love
party he really pushes forward mafia
like nobody want your the most like
passionate person I've seen like in
regards to party like ever yeah I'm not
the rules guy in the back to Mike you
know guys that's not with them yeah
reading the rulebook at the fifty both
the producers like I didn't read that
rule it's it's buried in there it's like
if you go to the sub-sect and you can
find it yeah but section three paragraph
two line numbers weight labret oh yeah
he's had a good JK party well I also I'm
I feel honored because at the time of
this recording I'm the last person to
edit a video on just kidding films and
we're hanging with JK is the one with
part in red underwear yes yeah he also
has you also do you're also author to
kennel like yeah I think you see it
before JK I was demo and YouTube channel
they have my book I did not giving
definitely brought those I don't think I
brought those that was actually the
subtle
we have a logo he's got a logo legit
like three options Oh picture show that
author picture look at that look at that
classy man fine you can get up there
give us a preview on what your latest
thing is though oh I know there's gonna
be like a plug shot by hand so I just
made my first comic book ever because I
want to go to Comic Cons next year
because I was like oh if I'm gonna come
across selling books I probably should
have a comic book at a comic convention
so I was like oh let me just do this
it's based on the first chapter of the
kishi which you saw Devon have it's
gonna go it's fresh but that's a new
thing the whole writing thing is like
only in the last two years that I've
wanted to start doing that and venture
into that beforehand as you were saying
YouTube channel had a youtube channel
that took the YouTube channel they'll
have it right now it's just that it's
like less so because it focusing more on
Jacob do you know I know many things
like that you're working on right now
yeah yeah I do have a lot yeah I have
the GA thing I have the writing things
that have my own YouTube channel which
right now is like avatar last airbender
focus but previously with Star Wars but
it it Harry Potter I have some app Game
of Thrones in there as well so geeky
stuff like like do you want to know who
would win between Baltimore and Vader
the answer is maybe
how does Vader beat magic oh wait I was
gonna give them answers and get all
geeky with it video these are dad no dad
no Vader's Oh Vader's now they said I
was like that's that's here sir
funny I mention that we had a pregnancy
scare recently and I was like wait do
you know something I told bro do that be
impressive a very nice no oh boy a dream
last night
you've always had a dream there oh Jesus
that's me but who's next Jimmy's next hi
I'm Devon by Antoine's book it's on
Amazon what is there to say holy crap
you know what favorites that man yeah
and Devon has been with JK forever since
I feel like any even before me and
before Brandon yeah yeah you were there
you brought me in and you brought Kyle
and we'll be here later hopefully if he
finishes the job
no that's the crazy I realize on the
drive up I'm like is there a reason that
a majority of who JK hires has all been
Long Beach students like we all went to
the same power cuz of you I was talking
to Joe about this and he had a theory
that a lot of the Long Beach students
just had a different kind of not work
like he said work ethic but I think more
than that it's like we gel well with
people I think like I think our
personalities aren't so and you describe
this of some of the other film schools
that they're a little bit cutthroat and
then there will be like like cut like
you know the undercut people they're
willing to like you know go to the extra
mile to kind of be messy with people and
for the most part my experience is with
Long Beach people my friends you know
people that I know here and stuff we're
all pretty friendly we all kind of want
to see each other succeed and so I think
that's why it works really well for this
company personally I was actually really
curious about how we would have gotten
along if we knew each other in college I
mean I got college I didn't know you and
I was very different
oh yeah yeah Brenda you also were from
Long Beach no he went to I mean I know
we get along like that's the reason why
all a there's an editing job just do it
Ryan yeah it was like hey you want to go
meet JK up on the roof and that was the
first time I doesn't that's the first
time you and I met I think - yeah and
like and we the first time we met
yes was that shoe
was the one with like the makeup artist
comes out and stuff like that in Italy
David was a director and he's directing
bard and Noah having like hygiene
yeah like let you kill my father and I
remember that day because I was trying
to lay out the ground rules of like what
what is allowed on the rooftop and I
said no climbing up to this waterway
that one day I remember though and of
course Devon sounds like he would know
it was a random other extra that was
like she's like and then there's no
climbing on anything really tall like we
don't want to get hurt and then and then
he's just here from the dis is like okay
I think I'm wider than Yoshi no he
wasn't there a random extra yes that
person was like seven stories up to like
because we already like three stories up
no they were already at the top no yeah
no that's up saying they're at the top
we're already like three stories up on
the roof yeah and then they were like an
additional like three or four that
building is still there in LA like I
Drive by it I don't like it so the
timing of it was perfect though it's
like alright everyone don't mind MUP and
Nelson you're okay just whips around and
you know the links make you do a lot of
crazy though cuz like let me sell like
me a Ryan man in college me and Antoine
actually met in elementary school middle
school middle school and we also have
the same taste in girls apparently too
cuz we both dated or were with or
involved with to the same girl same girl
but separate times entirely wasn't it
wasn't like the one like we'd like them
at the same time it was Kelly usher song
you two right there yeah you know you
know Antoine like a long time because I
remember you talking about him before I
ever met him and stuff because my other
friend that does like like lightsaber
stuff and something like
the thing is like Antoine is the most
diligent person like the fact that we
just list off site are you're an author
youtuber he's a Renaissance man you're a
man but not only in the sense of like
the modern day well we're the modern one
I feel like it's kind of tunics its
dumbed down because now everyone is
everything whether had a necessity or
just had a passion but Antoine is
legitimately great at the stuff he does
I'm a less successful dog lover
[Laughter]
he was already kilogram that time he was
thirty like a mug be thirty I don't know
actually doesn't mean by the time you're
sorry an Emmy at this point
actually what do you guys think it would
be like if you guys all like met each
other I mean well I know that I was very
antisocial in college just because I our
projects took me a long time and so I
would never spend or hang out with
anybody like spend time we're hanging
out with anybody just because I was just
drawing all the time yeah you think cool
just cuz we're both weaves we're also
like we're not su but we you you got so
college is a wrong time to believe out
with me just because I actually stayed
away from Adam II just because when I in
animation we learn a lot about like
American animation so it's just kind of
like you don't want to be influenced by
other oh I guess it's not books great
influence in your style too much purses
like you know you're studying in a craft
of doing American animation right gotcha
I mean now it's just mean that quick
also you would have had if she's like
super shy and like anti-social you'd
have to like crack that she'll you'd
have to become friends with her and then
you'd have to like be like hey feeling
feeling in her store you with her friend
Aki it she's basically this she
basically that was the same way that you
befriended me
you should you should tell that story
how you met how you make friends that
you really want to be friends
step one via creeper yeah step to really
observe them for a really long time
step three really make them feel
uncomfortable and then step four be
friends it's not a method we would have
recommend no I tried to do that on tip
one time and she really got scared she
thought I was gonna kill her right mood
for that no I I realized that it doesn't
work on everyone but on the people that
it's two people I mean two three right
[Laughter]
it was dope being Julia the first time
when I was first coming up in JK party
but I got disappointed with you like
stick around mid-roll yeah the reason
was cooking at that time fancy fifteen
had come out waiting for only like DISA
and just Justin who's someone we know
like we're into it I was looking for
other people who I knew like in physical
friendships realm who's fine yeah I got
talked about the story I think it's a
point about no Julia oh my god start
talking about like France to teach like
what about this anime this had missions
like there's so much more feel like not
really and I just remember you kept
forgetting that I wasn't in Final
Fantasy or like I wasn't up to date like
five different occasions at all like I
had this conversation with that so
before it every single time you brought
it up you're so disappointed in me and I
like credit like when he usually brings
something up that he knows he's asked
about before he's really quickly about
that every single time you know what
after like the line
how about that you know I'm gonna
[ __ ] watch like the experts like on
YouTube but you know what though you
know I I kind of we could talk about it
we can talk about some of these you
don't ever ask her every good you never
did about 13 inch ones just like I
[ __ ] hate it I just want to talk
about how much I hate it you know who
would enjoy talking about Final Fantasy
with you - oh I cheated
doh yeah guys met her Nelson yet but
she's right Nelson just like Nelson I
guess he's huge
it's funny because sometimes he'll like
help you know he was when he was helping
out with ambarish shoot he was just
walking around like moving stuff and
then one of the other like producers
came up it was like hey I don't freezing
in the buff Jack dude we were playing
softball together and when you came up
to bat my dad's like all those muscles
watch out guys because before your dad
hit the winning hit he was telling
Nelson who think muscles you're too
shallow man you gotta go further back
and then Nelson was just like but yeah
so it's Julia we do we do we cover Jill
I mean that was that was my segue -
Julia taking news and I used to host a
aki-nee's long long time ago until I was
like mmm Coolidge a kitty but now she's
back
look she's back as like as a as a guest
cast yeah and then moving on Hey look
this me
they know me I've been here I used to do
Ryan's job really yeah oh did you min-ho
I was like hosting right now how was the
first one you taught me you taught me
how to be really taught all of us what I
do now run Jake a party I download all
the media that these guys at is for news
you know it helps a lot
pictures I organize it for TIFF the
videos too but yeah I've been with JK
for like six years and a little bit of
everything literally I've edited every
video on every channel I can think of
even edited vlogs I've been on camera
I've been behind the camera and barbell
and bar yeah yeah I've been like I've
been just like tip like what do you use
their term jack-of-all-trades er I'm
like Jack yeah I'm not the best at
everything but I'm a jack of all trades
master of aberration Swiss Army Choi
don't have a knife I'll get his face
engraved on a Swiss Army knife we
actually need a Swiss Army knife oh yeah
he's our MacGyver I have a multi-tool on
me Wow Ryan this is Christmas oh yeah
this is Christmas gift to me was this I
don't know what you even call this SH
it's called a gerber chard it's all very
good it's like a screwdriver it's got a
bottle opener it's got a whole bunch of
stuff on there yeah yeah oh this man the
guy who got me to carry it I just as
utility all the time now yeah and she's
speaking of which Sean it is your turn
it's my turn what do you want to know
about me Ryan start from the beginning
oh yeah I guess I guess from when you
start like hon man yeah he's our pun man
he is also a like editor your camera guy
you're a little bit everything too but I
mean I feel like you as far as I've
known you in the company like I've sort
of come to you for editing things
because I think that that was your kind
of specialty I don't know if that's
still very true anymore or if you're
kind of flexing in other things but I
mean yeah I just start from wherever for
the company
I am camera op one of the camera crew
members for JK party
I guess the DI T digital imaging
technician so every time we finish
shooting a JK party video I'll take all
the SD card
or can I put them all into the big drive
that we have organized all of them and
and sort it so that Antwon editor
extraordinary but Nelson Nelson to super
day Nelson's not here in the future to
do another one of these later we'll
bring that is not my voice it's not
muscles Nelson oh right sorry yeah I
didn't know if I saw that the same time
we'll just we'll shoot three plates with
Nelson's and so each table they can be
there yeah yeah so then they'll sit in
here it will record the whole thing
they'll sit it there I'll record the
whole thing and I'll sit in there and
over for the whole thing and they'll
just stitch it together but you'll get
that's a crew joke you would never hear
that from castle after nerds well we
could just do an entire episode we'll be
deep fake porn but you know but Shan
Shan was one of the first people who
came after me and Brandon yeah into the
company yeah and then I brought in Byron
and Nelson motorcycle Mills not Muslim
[Music]
Oh a picture no we don't have one in
here I still have the stickers in one
day I'll hide one yeah that's mainly
what I do I just do a lot of JK party I
do a lot of editing I edit news I feel
in tech when you and pattern available
to outside of that I I guess I managed
the disk quit server I stream on my
twitch channel and I have a small
youtube channel and you also like
freelance at it on the side right yeah
we need oh yeah you're still a
freelancer I freelance for CLG before
that they're an eSports team they're
located over in Culver they play a lot
of league they've got a lot of like
different teams for like port and I apex
and all the other various games and so I
had it for them on occasion great team
yeah that's what I do
not much so I guess it's my turn now
yeah so I'm right
[Music]
yeah so I'm uh I've been with the
company for years three or four years
I've no I think four cuz I've been here
five you know how I know that is because
you're on probation before the big man
yeah I didn't get to go to Japan yeah
ironic cuz I only went to Japan like
really recently like this last six
months yeah exactly so but I've I'm so
I'm primary I'd like to think of myself
as a camera man but I do a little bit
everything to edit for JK news ice-t--
added a little bit of party here and
there I am the director of photography
for JK party so I sort of manage all the
crew members and camera people and I
sort of just lights depending on what
what kind of mood were going for I don't
know if you guys have seen our like
Halloween videos and stuff think the
Halloween video is coming up pretty soon
for this year - it'll get real moody
there so that's a lot of fun I just like
using cameras and stuff so I do mostly
that but I'm also yeah like I said jack
of all trades kind of like always have a
gadget I mean fix things open things are
yeah the funny thing is we always I just
remember I never saw you on campus oh
yeah we went to school at the same time
and I never saw him on campus ever until
he got the job here and I started seeing
him like no it was literally like the
week after I got hired like I was
walking in one of the fa buildings at
Long Beach and then we were walking down
the stairs and then here and then he was
he was that was the first time I ever
saw Ryan on campus until then he never
existed - it's real weird yeah cuz it's
a I'm Solid four years along I think was
five for you writer yeah I was at Long
Beach for five years you were there
never saw each other once wait do we
start working here before we graduated
yeah at least you did I know that but I
mean like when I came back it was my
senior year you you hit me up midway
through my senior year so that's when I
started yeah so Bros II don't know yeah
I I came back when a like the Daniel
days and Oh Daniel Klein
yeah
he's a doctor now or he's trying to be
done here I replace that guy yeah he's a
nuggets guy yeah yeah yeah so I was here
before news existed if you look at the
first three videos I'm the editor on
that as well as like when we start
troubleshooting all this but yeah I left
after a few years and then me Sean and
was a Lauren or kaiju like that were the
initial launching three cuz that brought
I brought in Lauren as well got you yeah
everybody Brody yeah the first two waves
were all Sean hires and the third wave
was my hires
and then afterwards I can think we just
kind of were done yeah after the third
say yeah I think it was third set of
hires and then Pat came in later but
aside from that he was more to help out
on like party and other stuff but as far
as the news hires yeah I think it was me
and Kyle were the last ones in as far as
like people doing news and then yeah
yeah it's been a good ride but yeah if
you guys enjoyed that video if you guys
enjoyed this crew chemistry that we got
going on feel free to go and hit
subscribe like the video and yo stay
tuned because we got more of these
videos coming thanks guys they have Pat
coming oh he's refusing to come out oh
don't be shy
you guys you can't force areas yeah
and I've got a broken arm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]